[Applaudissements]
essayez de penser
essayez de penser aux moments les plus
extraordinaires au dessus
12 ans
plus marqué
sans pression c'est le groupe
voilà je sens le besoin de bons
donc je disais essayer de penser aux
moments les plus extraordinaires de
votre vie au monde qui vous ont le plus
marqué à ces choses que vous avez
accompli et dont vous êtes les plus
fiers
vous remarquez mise en commun que vous
étiez probablement sortie de votre zone
de confort
on pense souvent à bord de la zone de
confort c'est un ensemble de choses
agréables qui ramène du plaisir et de la
joie dans nos vies en fait le mot
confort est très trompeur
la vraie définition de la zone de
confort c'est un ensemble de situations
positives ou négatives qui font un
ensemble une sorte de plus familière
pour notre cerveau est dedans on se pose
aucune question
on ne réfléchit pas on prend pas de
décision
on est vraiment en mode pilote
automatique ne jamais sortir de sa zone
de confort c'est quelque part risquez de
passer à côté de sa vie c'est vraiment
rester dans le mode par défaut en mode
aléatoire
si vous n'avez sûrement d'or de
recherche sortir de sa zone de confort
vous aurez des images de son parachute
escalade de plongée et j'en passe mais
sortir de sa zone de confort n'est pas
que ça pour certaines personnes ça peut
être tout simplement ne rien faire ça
peut même prendre du temps pour soi pour
une fois ça peut n'être lâcher prise en
fait la notion est très subjectif et est
différente d'une personne à une autre
je rappelle aline et vous l'aurez
peut-être compris la zone de confort
c'est un peu mon obsession
au point que j'en ai fait mon métier à
temps plein il ya un peu plus de deux
ans je vais dépenser le défi suivant
celui de sorties représentent de gros
foire au moins une fois par jour pendant
365 jours/an toute une année je pourrais
parler moment désordre cette expérience
tellement extraordinaire vous raconter
tellement d'anecdotes mais si j'ai à
retenir qu'une seule chose qu'une seule
qu'un seul enseignement ça c'est
probablement le suivant il n'est pas
nécessaire de faire des choses
traoré nerfs pour obtenir des résultats
extraordinaires par eux mêmes c'est
complètement la res il suffit de toutes
petites actions de toutes petites
décisions pour provoquer à perdre et
résultats extraordinaires
je ne sais pas si vous êtes familier
avec ce concept on appelle l'effet
papillon qui peut être résumée dans la
phrase suivante les battements d'aile
d'un papillon peut suffire pour
provoquer à terme une tempête en fait
l'idée derrière ce cpe et s'est dit
suffit parfois juste de modifier un
paramètre initiale dans une situation
départ pour à terme provoquer des
résultats et des conséquences colossales
des exemples comme ça dans la grande
histoire
il y en a des centaines pour n'en citer
qu'un seul par exemple je peux voir
mauvais l'histoire de septembre il
s'appelait rosa mars
c'était une afro américaine et il ya un
peu plus de 60 ans qui a décidé un jour
le diamant elle a décidé de ne plus
céder sa place comme il était usage à un
blanc pour le plus cette simple décision
cette simple action va provoquer et va
faire le début du mouvement de lutte
contre la ségrégation raciale
une simple action une simple question
mais ce concept qui reste valable pour
chacun donc nos propres vies chacun a
tous notre proposition propres histoires
je peux par exemple vous raconter ce
jour il ya un peu plus de deux ans où
j'ai pris tout simplement la décision
hyper simple de descendre deux stations
de métro avant mon arrêt habituel très
simples comme décision emma je pense que
sans cette décision là je ne serais
probablement pas là ce soir a par là sur
cette scène devant vous vous êtes en
train de me méfier des scénarios mais ce
qui s'est passé
en fait cette inflexion ce soir là je
suis passé par un autre trajet et j'ai
découvert ce petit restaurant ce petit
bar à salades on les appelle maintenant
qui faisait de la nourriture saine
j'ai décidé de prendre un repas et ce
soir là j'avais remarqué que mon niveau
d'énergie il était largement plus haut
que d'habitude je ne me sentais plus
aussi fatigué que tous les soirs vous
dire qu'à l'époque je vous nourrit c'est
essentiellement de fast food de plats
préparés de pizza de cochonneries gras
sucrés et c est cette première
expérience va donner envie de me lancer
dans d'autres
l'arrêté sucre pendant 30 jours doit
s'interposer et petit à petit j'ai eu
l'idée de créer ce blog ou une bague en
forme zone et de me lancer dans le
projet des 365 jours une décision ultra
simple peut provoquer des conséquences
et peut vous faire sortir de ce mode par
défaut je peux aussi vous citer cette
fois où j'ai décidé d'accueillir des
inconnus chez moi les touristes sur mon
canapé et comment je me suis retrouvé
six mois plus tard accueillis dans un
pays étranger reçu comme un prince à
vivre une expérience extraordinaire de
voyage comme jeu
jamais vécu je pourrais également voir
des sept fois où j'ai pris mon courage
pour partir à 7 soit l'année la serre où
je connaissais personne que tout le
monde se connaissait
j'étais malade j'avais envie de rentrer
chez moi mais j'ai décidé de rester un
peu tard puis de prendre un verre le
plus pur à deuxième mais pas ce soir là
si j'avais pas pris cette décision à si
j'étais entré un peu plus tôt j'aurais
jamais rencontré celle qui aujourd'hui
est devenue la femme de ma vie et qui
est la norme assad
bad ragaz q j'ai rencontré personne ce
soir là sa bonne saison je vois la main
je vous rappelle mais cette fois j'ai
décidé de m'arrêter pour une fois pour
partager un repas
ce sont d'abord et qui prennent à côté
de chez moi et prendre le temps
d'écouter son histoire en fait je me
suis repris une claque ce jour là qui
allait complètement changer la vie sur
davy rendre beaucoup plus positif est
beaucoup plus ouvert d'esprit et c'est
probablement grâce à ce déclic là que
j'ai eue ce jour là bas que j'ai eus
droits à quelques mois plus tard de
quitter mon job pour le consacrer à ma
passion et créer aux entreprises quelle
est cette décision quelle est cette
petite action que les états risquent
d'être qui vous fait peur et que vous
pouvez accomplir dès aujourd'hui pour
tendance est meilleure nation vous même
pour accomplir ses objectifs qui vous
tiennent à coeur pour tout simplement
explorer de nouvelles possibilités
la vie est vraiment un jeu aux
possibilités illimitées et chaque action
en or notre zone de confort peut être le
début d'une nouvelle aventure
avant de jouer
[Applaudissements]